the rolex 24 Hours of Daytona is it the
most popular car race in America and
it's not the richest but running from
240 p.m. saturday to 240 p.m. sunday it
is definitely the longest and with
plenty of racing wealth behind it it is
definitely the most prestigious
the goal of the race is to see how many
times you can complete the three and a
half mile circuit in 24 hours it's a
grueling commitment for the cars the
teams and the spectators so of course I
had to see the Rolex 24 for myself and
it makes perfect sense that this would
be the site of the debut runner for
Ford's new racing car the four GT you
know the one board has hyped it for a
year and we saw the four hundred
thousand dollar production version of it
in Detroit in January expectations were
high for this year's team it's three
drivers would have to alternate quickly
while on the track if a car looks good
it usually goes fast there's a lot of
performance in the car that we haven't
even tapped yet before the race throngs
of fans mostly American crowded around
the car watching this machine get
prepped for his long haul was pretty
intense and you could feel the energy in
the garage as the driving team practice
the switch offs they'd make over the
course of the race
the GT started strong but was quickly
overtaken by some race veterans from
Porsche Audi and Corvette and the Ford
GT had some shall we say growing pains
throughout the race alternately stalling
spinning and heading into the pits for
mechanical adjustments then again in
this racing series that is to be
expected
in the hours between pit stops the crew
grabbed catnaps where they could but
it's hard to sleep when some of the
fastest cars in the world are jockeying
for position just feet away
in the end the Ford GT didn't quite do
as well as poked Honda one in the
overall standings the Ford GT finished
in the middle of its class ford is going
to win it's a question about when they
might not win the roads 24 but they are
going to win at one stage with that car
but all is not lost not by a long shot
this race is a proving ground for the
future the engines brakes suspension and
transmission are all the best and
fastest system sport has developed a
date and as the car races again and
again and again those systems will
improve eventually they will be polished
enough to put into the car soul to
people like you and me I can't wait